hello and welcome them 20 playing pixie
with white okay I'm playing all the guys
we have a bad school against 13 oops
wonderful a strange opening Joe just
looks quite weird to be perfectly honest
Black has weakened him serve enormously
so let's see how to do it probably what
okay let's see how to how to punish this
so let's see queen bee three maybe yeah
probably a couple of good moves
available here tell us it seems like he
wants to get this game almost as quickly
somehow
okay 95 historical Queen to e7 so how to
do it
26 I guess this should be success 95
I'm sorry this should be six yeah there
should be six s95
yeah like is rapidly running out of
moves him yeah it's not very surprising
if you move your King's Knight four
times and weaken every square available
that you have like g5 and so on taking
on c3 taking on you very very
provocative opening sure my score was
atrocious against and now he lets the
clock run down or what is the concept
okay
okay 95 I guess so it says something
better can also check g5 first but again
it probably doesn't make a big
difference okay so i can take the five
twice I just wonder if there is
something something even better
available I can actually think about
taking this this is this is not a bad
idea actually and now I can take the
five twice Knight takes c6 through p1
unfortunately it's check so okay I'll
just take this toys editing f5
Queen f7 is still not completely simple
to refute think probably maybe here
shoot 45 all 95 I can also be a good
idea and put it back only five okay so
let's go to five
you
c6 as a threat now okay yeah it's not
that easy here it's not that easy keep
c5 for the moment fattening would be
seven again yep that wasn't very
convincing the game this game should
have been over quite a while ago but it
didn't so they didn't manage to finish
it off ok let's see that i'm not back or
animated
don't mind that much like to go to e6
yeah it looks like a very nice position
now I mean it did before but now it
looks like very good control so anyway
to get quickly to g7 wants to try Roxy
five maybe I ok maybe I should just play
c6 TX roof c6 to get that pawn no it's
not it's not super clear ok but this is
good for [ __ ] c7 now
time warning check black resins a fade a
super provocative opening um yeah a
success already is just a bad move
because I get in he for which is the
idea and oops yeah this looks probably
it's close to unplayable this pollution
black said like has so many weaknesses
now he gives me the dark squares and
it's thought at least see takes the
thing is this is so bad it should be
over in much quicker I didn't I didn't
kill him off he efficiently the engine
is already on plus 3 m there should be
seven and now it gives a for with plus 4
yeah quite easy to imagine maybe this
wasn't so good this is just + 2.5 but ok
2.5 is not that bad okay Ruby six is
clearer plus this plus 6 okay I didn't
quite understand why I have still have
95 of course simple after Bishop be 695
wins be seven and the rook so he has to
take with the Queen and this is then
even even worse there because I get
everything with tempo I mean he has
nothing out totally lost him okay + 8 or
whatever and okay well this is also yeah
in terms of the comp + 3 e but the game
should have been over but I'm
at least I'm not giving it away entirely
this is good always keep this big
advantage when it could have been we
could have been finished much quicker he
simply weakened so many squares and
pawns that that was far too much for one
position in one game okay thanks for
watching